كما قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن ان تكلفه الهجمات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على المدنيين في قطاع غزه لا
تزال مرتفعه للغايه واضاف ان فريقا تابعا
للامم المتحده بدا مهمه في شمال غزه
لتقييم اوضاع المدنيين الذين مازالوا هناك
وتقييم ما يجب القيام به للسماح
للفلسطينيين النازحين بالعوده الى
ديارهم بدا فريق الامم المتحده مهمته في
شمال غزه لتقييم اوضاع المدنيين الذين ما
زالوا هناك وكذلك ما يجب القيام به للسماح
للفلسطينيين النازحين بالعوده الى ضيار في
الشمال ومع ذلك كما قلت لرئيس الوزراء
وللمسؤولين اسرائيليين اخرين اليوم فان
الخسائر اليوميه التي تواصل العمليه
العسكريه الحاقها بالمدنيين الابرياء لا
تزال مرتفعه
للغايه